jetzt kommt jetzt kombi älteres oft ich
hab früher eine zeit wow gespielt ja
richtig schlimm da war ich habe dieses
spiel gelegt und liebe es eigentlich was
eigentlich mit das geistes spiel was ich
je gespielt haben das habe ich fast zwei
jahre also zwei jahre lang gespielt und
so lange habe ich auch noch nie ein
spiel gespielt
also dann am ende war ich auch ziemlich
ich sag mal ich nicht um mich süchtig
aber ich habe ja viel zeit haben sehr
viel zeit in dieses spiel gesteckt aber
die meisten die meisten spaß am spiel
eigentlich da gemacht als ich von level
0 bis level irgendwas gelevelt bin also
als ich das spiel gerade erforscht hat
die welt kennengelernt habe alles wo
alles noch komplett neu war das spiel
richtig viel spaß gemacht ich wollte was
schon schwerer
so in der pvp erinnert als ich war so
der ob über pro wirklich also ich war
richtig abgegangen
auf dem server weichen der am besten
gilde werden alles geredet pvp war ich
voll sei es merkt ja nix ja es muss doch
nicht die leute nicht verstehen ich
verstehen aber am ende trotzdem obwohl
ich eigentlich so alle erfolge die man
im spiel so bekommen kann ja erlebt habe
mir am anfang als ich ein kompletter
kuba am meisten spaß gemacht
das sollte erzählen dass spieler am
anfang eigentlich größten reiz haben
wenn sie neu sind und also ich bin gar
kein gamer es gab kein spiel doch mw3
habe ich anfangs so was von unglaublich
viel gelüftet das war echt nicht mehr
normal und zwar erreicht auch relativ
gut nur nicht lange mit ein paar sachen
bei mir ne kiste nur ich habe mir dann
einfach gesagt weil
es hat mir eigentlich die ganze zeit
spaß macht vor allem wenn man dort hält
immer wieder prestige hoch gehen konnte
weil dann hat man darf natürlich nicht
mehr muss ich dann das wir aufbauen
attackiert plattform multiplayer
natürlich und vor allem auch weil wir so
eine art plan hatten und dann da immer
herum gelaufen sind und einfach alles
weg gebracht hatten was er in den weg
gestellt hat hat es eigentlich sehr sehr
viel spaß gemacht dessen ende man jemand
bei männern ist es cool
nur die sache war halt die dass ich mit
der zeit festgestellt habe dass dadurch
meine schulnoten doch stark nachgelassen
haben zehn arbeitsverhalten bzw
die schulnoten einfach die schulischen
leistungen deswegen habe ich meine nase
gefasst habe gedacht kommt ins
deinstalliert mw3 einfach mal damit gar
nicht in versuchung kommt den minuten
runde zu spielen und es hat deutlich was
gebracht also mittlerweile ist echt so
durch diese aktion nicht nur noch
wirklich vom pc wenn ich sage ich mal
weiß okay machst etwas produktives zum
beispiel video aufnehmen oder englisch
schulaufgabe machen und mal ich habe
dadurch gelernt sich prioritäten zu
setzen wer damals war es durch kommata
schule erstmal runde mit 3 oder
irgendwie sowas zweiten runde dauert
zehn minuten viertelstunde oder so und
der hausaufgaben hast du nachher unter
nebel ist es nachher wieder unter links
ins bett da keine hausaufgaben mehr kann
ich machen muss und ein zügiger
verlaufen
also wartet noch mit mir ganz kurz die
sachen die unterlagen ich bin auf dem
weg lag die show marien und jedenfalls
dagegen gleich alle leute die irgendwie
besser nicht sollen sein tun werden
machen haben und ihr zockt dann den
steht einfach die spiele wirklich das
hilft hilft wenn ihr damit aufhören
wollte also ich weiss ich extrem süchtig
aber dass er so in erfahrung ich habe
gefragt also ich hab halt auch früher
dadurch schuleit ein bisschen
nachgelassen
wenn man halt so 24/7 wow zocker und
dann habe ich halt auch einfach weil ich
gemerkt habe dass bist du gerade im bett
ich bin auf dem weg
ich habe einfach dann aufgehört weil ich
halt auch gemerkt hab einfach das
creeper dass ich dadurch hat
nachgelassen habe und realität umsetzen
ja in der heiße ich hab eigentlich die
gleiche erfahrung gemacht wie du und
danach hab ich auch also jetzt ähnlich
wie die hits geschrieben was eine
richtige zocker unlust das heißt ich
habe gar kein spiel mehr angefasst und
habe wirklich nichts mehr gezockt und
ich hatte auch also ich habe jetzt auch
als ich hatte nie wissen gamer pc aber
den hatte ich zu der zeit mehr zusammen
gestellt als ich halt noch gezockt habe
jetzt gerade noch so am ende dieser
phase und danach hatte ich wirklich ein
jahr lang habe ich nichts mehr spielt
ich habe meine ausbildung begonnen haben
einfach kein bock mehr irgendwas am pc
zu spielen weil ich alles irgendwie als
zeitverschwendung gesehen habt aber auch
aber im moment ist es wieder hat es
wieder komplett geklärt also ich hab
halt mit minecraft angefangen durch
justin also und er hat mir gesagt
willkommen
wir können die am 1 5 spielen und so das
vollständig kaufen ich kann erst mal so
ein crack ding geben dann spielt das
erst mal korrekt und guckt ihr an wenn
es dir gefällt und so habe ich gesagt ja
okay und ich fand das spiel so
eigentlich so cool habe immer gedacht
ich schieße ich dann gespielt
ich werde wieder deinstallieren ich gar
keine zeit habt dafür und keine ahnung
jetzt macht sie wieder richtig viel spaß
und ich sehe solche zeitverschwendung
weil ich mir halt einfach jetzt viel
besser einteilen kann also ich weiß
jetzt einfach ich bin jetzt so ich habe
so viel erfahrung gesammelt ist dass ich
weiß wann ich mir meine zeit wie
einteilen kann genau ist auch mal dass
das ich auch mein land zocken kann ohne
dass irgendwelche üblichen konsequenzen
für meinen für mein leben hat genau und
das wollte ich auch echt mal auf
zurückgreifen muss wirklich erstmal
einmal die erfahrung gemacht haben dass
man es wirklich realisiert
die gehälter sind so schlau die geben
wenn sie brennen wirklich ein haus rein
sehr klug ich kann ich aus meinem haus
nicht leer aus ich glaube mein haus
wieder falle ich kann sein haus nicht
mehr aus der warte ich komm zieh dir ich
bin raus habe ich habe ich frei
geschaufelt so kannst du bitte mit mir
kommen und versuchen also mir zu helfen
items wiederzukriegen vorjahren unter
sich
ich wollte ich ja ihre it konzerne zeigt
man alive einfallen und ich helfe dann
kommt versucht ihr keine sachen zu
klauen
nein also sprichwörtlich das wasser wir
bauen auf jeden fall eine brücke
definitiv ja
und zwar finde ich auch dass man einmal
die erfahrung machen muss damit man so
etwas lernt das ist eigentlich bei allen
sachen so ich bin allgemein ein fechter
auf die theorie dass man alles
ausprobieren sollte bevor man darüber
urteilt sage ich mal
bevor man irgendwas die höhle kritisiere
er aber es ist ein kripo-sprecher
nachricht die hülle ist ihr gewesen komm
mit ich hab ich hoffe die items diesmal
nicht so schnell es geht weiter
bei mir was ich damals so dass ich mir
überhaupt nicht die zeit einteilen
konnte dann habe ich wirklich aufgehört
mit mp3 und hab mich dann wirklich ich
hatte wirklich wie ihr schon gesagt dass
so eine unlust auf socken einfach nicht
einfach überhaupt keinen bock
ich sass vom pc und habe gedacht er
konnte bis am rennen bis am hochrhein
für die nächsten fünf tage nicht alles
veröffentlicht kümmerlich doch einfach
mal die schule oder in dieser was und
dadurch wird man das wirklich
durch erfahrung sage ich mal und seine
erfahrung muss man machen kinder das
sagen euch hier mami und papi
rumgespielt erwartet wo soll ich jetzt
design weiter
ja ich hab ja ich hab alles wieder bin
ich gekommen
ja ich dachte vielleicht braucht er
nicht
dann aber habe ich schön gebaut diese
mine damit zu treffen und alles vor
allem hier sind über all diese marmor
steine oder als trio wieder marmor stein
und eisen dreht wieder hier
vorhin auch schon ein medley etwas gab
es nur noch links haben wir gesund
allerdings das eine ist eine große
bissig wird wir hier ja ich habe unter
wasser mittel gefunden
ich hoffe es mit einer spiele ich bin
gerade selber in einer höhle beschäftigt
euch erschüttern ich habe einen zombie
brain hier habe ich auch nicht mitmachen
der schaufel der hand und die sind
richtig übel nicht abbauen noch eine
doppelt ist muss er erst mit stolen
präsent als blogger machen nix kult
wenn jetzt ist wie immer einfach in die
comments ich stelle schon wieder das ist
uns schon wieder kann laufen oder so ja
der ist schneller oder die kug so
komisch ich mag dich wirklich nicht mehr
ich mag wirklich vorkämpfe kein denkmal
bitte ich es mir einfach dazu kasse und
story präsent aber damit kann man nichts
machen irgendwie verstehen nicht ich
gehe wieder zurück meine bühne
fürchtegott ein herz muss sowas von viel
erde abbauen damit wir dass da hinten
irgendwie machen können wollte es noch
irgendwas zu einer zucker erfahrung
erzählen glaube ich oder ja wie gesagt
als ich hatte halt wirklich dieses in
diese zwei extremen seiten kennengelernt
also einmal wirklich den ganzen tag mit
runtergelassen jalousien und das war bei
mir aber nicht sein es muss ich sein
also ich hab wirklich richtig heftig
gesucht ist also ich hab wirklich ich
war so ein richtiger wow sucht die wie
im bilderbuch
das ist nichts gegen die spieler also
wie gesagt ich liebe dieses spiel immer
noch ich jetzt nicht mehr spielen weil
es einfach zurzeit ensi für mich ist und
mir ist wahrscheinlich kein spaß machen
würde aber die zeiten spieltag war eine
sehr sehr geile zeit also ich hab also
ich hab das mit ich habe viele leute
kennengelernt viele freunde und alles
hat wirklich eigentlich zu der zeit wo
ich gespielt habe auch nur wow freunde
gehabt also auch nur so leute die es dem
spiel gelernt hab hab mein relief total
vernachlässigt habe meine freunde total
vernachlässigt habe eigentlich alles
komplett vernachlässigt und das kann
vielleicht auch richtig heftig und dann
war ich in der stadt manchmal so und hab
mir etwas gekauft eine hose oder so und
ich konnte ich mal richtig mehr mit
leuten soziale konversationen führen als
ob jan eitel so heftig dass ich eure
geräten konnte so aber ich hatte total
hemmungen höheren getrimmt mit zu
sprechen und so wie teuer ist diese hose
ja fünf aurea hier am see fünf gold im
moment der kristall zeichen über dem
kopf wir reden also ich hatte wirklich
hemmungen mit menschen zu sprechen ich
nicht kannte und solche sachen also ich
habe wirklich
also es war wirklich schon es war
wirklich hart an der grenze des
selbstmords sein
also ich habe auf jeden fall sucht ich
sag mal sucht er vorm spiel gemacht
allerdings ging es dann dann war es zeit
und hat mich hatte ich das denn
zurückgeholt auf die richtige spur
jahren erzähle ich dir jetzt verdammt
dann wird world of warcraft zu zeiten
von burning crusade gespielt dann kam
dagmar raste lich king
natürlich ging nach salz können thorsten
fink das in gesprächen auf jeden fall
kam es dann raus und zu der zeit hatte
ich dann auch schon nicht so viel lust
auf wow weiß oder topp bilde und dann
muss sich auch in wow so viel zeit
aufbringen um tränke class und die
ganzen scheiße was man halt macht zu
fahren um im raid gut dazustehen und
greatest sonne rangliste oder wieder zur
welt ist so eine
also es wird mit 20 leuten und und macht
dann der instanz also eine höhle wo
viele schätzen und was bekommt halt